Psalm 30 I will extol you O Lord for you
have drawn me up and if not let my foes
rejoice over me O Lord my god I cried to
you for help and you have healed me O
Lord you have brought my soul up from
shale you restored me to life from among
those who go down to the pit sing
praises to the Lord oh you've his Saints
and give thanks to his holy name for his
anger is but for a moment his favor is
for a lifetime weeping may tarry for the
night but joy comes with the morning as
for me I said in my prosperity I shall
never be moved but your favor or Lord
you made my mountain stand strong you
hid your face I was dismayed to you O
Lord I cry and to the Lord I plead for
mercy what profit is there in my death
if I go down to the pit will the dust
praise you will it tell of your
faithfulness here O Lord and be merciful
to me O Lord be my helper you have
turned for me my mourning into dancing
you have loosed my sack cloth and
clothed me with gladness that my glory
may sing your praise and not be silent o
Lord my god I will give thanks to you
forever
well these certainly are peculiar times
aren't they a few days ago President
Donald Trump announced that the country
is on a certain wartime footing recently
a major manufacturers here in Michigan
like Ford announced that they were
retooling their plants to make medical
supplies just like they once retooled
their plants to make tanks and airplanes
nearly 80 years ago for World War two
international borders have been shut and
as of this moment nearly 1/4 of
America's population is now basically
living at home under lockdown in order
to prevent the spread of this disease we
Christians may well wonder in the face
of all this what is god up to we believe
that God is benevolent that he's good
that he rules this world and so we have
to ask is he in charge of any of this
how do we square his loving mercy with
what we are witnessing where is God in
the midst of this suffering now I think
we need to be very careful how we
approach this question as Christians on
the one hand the Scriptures are very
honest about the reality of human pain
human suffering they don't skirt over it
or dance around it you might even say
that the reality of human suffering is
the single most important thing driving
the narrative of salvation forward but
on the other hand scripture is does not
dance around this issue with faint
platitudes or naive notions the
Scriptures are equally clear that our
current sufferings are the inevitable
result of living in a fallen world a
world which groans our world which
groans under a curse that is brought
about let us be clear by our own
rebellion against God so what are God's
people to do in the midst of all of this
Psalm 30 actually offers us perhaps a
startling answer it opens with praise
which I suppose is an appropriate
antidote to what may be a temptation now
to a despair
I will magnify you Oh Lord for you have
lifted me up Oh Lord my god I cry to you
you have made me whole the psalmist says
the psalmist then continues to describe
his current predicament and relatively
relatable terms he describes in verse 6
that complacency which so easily beset
all of us in times of prosperity says in
my prosperity I said I shall never be
moved you O Lord of your goodness have
made my Hill strong isn't this how it
often feels like he's given the divine a
place for his current prosperity but
then something changes what happens when
times get tough when things get bad I'm
mindful of the story of Job and how he
says to his friends that should we
accept good from God and not the evil
when things get difficult
can we still give our God thanks and
praise the psalmist here seems to
understand the problem this is he gave
the divine hand a place for his good
fortune so he also seems to give it a
place for his bad he says in verse 7 you
turned your face from me and I was
distressed it was God Himself who seems
to be responsible at least by his very
absence and isn't that how it usually
feels that God is present with us and
our good times but he's absent and our
bad but notice what the psalmist does
notice how he makes our problem God's
problem in verse 10 he says shall the
dust give thanks to you or shall it
declare your faithfulness what profit is
there in my blood should if I go down
into the pit there's a simple logic here
God deserves to be praised by his
creatures
he is a good a benevolent an almighty an
all-wise creator it is fitting that he
should receive our praise and if we go
down into the pit if the works of his
hands cease to exist
he himself does not receive his proper
due does an audacity in this kind of
declaration the psalmist makes our
problem God's a problem he seems to
suggest that that God's own prerogative
as God requires him to act to defend us
his creature God's own glory is at stake
in our suffering
you might think this thought impious and
not even seem blasphemous on its face
but counter-intuitively
God Himself seems to agree he says you
have turned my lamentation into dancing
you have put off my sack cloth and Gerda
to me with gladness God has heard the
logic of this complaint and has acted to
deliver now we as Christians ought to
know far better than the psalmist for we
have seen how personally invested God is
in our suffering we have seen his glory
shine in the face of his son Jesus
Christ who was born a servant like us
who died the death that is our due he
rose to new life glorious new life that
we might have hope in him we have seen
how God cares in the life of Jesus the
logic of the season of Lent is that we
approach the cross of Jesus Christ in
this season and I am mindful of a prayer
in my own tradition which says this
Almighty God whose most dear son went
not up to joy but first he suffered pain
and entered not into glory before he was
crucified notice the logical sequence of
this so the prayer goes on mercifully
grant that we walking in the way of the
Cross may find it none other than life
and peace
how can we be so sure of this kind of
redemption that our suffering will be
turned to joy because we've seen in the
life of Jesus Christ's that there's no
profit it for God and our being down
fallen the world will know that he is a
good creator that he is a powerful
Redeemer the world will see it every
tongue will confess every knee will Bend
his own glory is at stake he will see it
done as we enter more fully into this
Lenten season let us remember God's own
personal investment and our hardships he
is capable of turning our suffering into
joy if we humbly go to him and call out
to him as the psalmist Himself modeled
for us in verse 8 of this song may we
follow his lead now